happy turkey time whether you're
celebrating Thanksgiving Christmas or
you just want to spend the next 6 hours
in the kitchen roasting a 20 pound girl
probably gonna be eating a lot of turkey
leftovers over the next few weeks and
sure you can put a little bit at poultry
on a piece of white bread and top it off
so little gravy and call it dinner
forward to those left the rules just as
much as original piece so that's why I
propelled my table go to healthy recipes
for getting that Tipler full of Turkey
and some other odds and ends a delicious
new life first up my cozy turkey chili
first i saute a medium diced onion and a
red and yellow bell pepper in a
tablespoon of olive oil until softened
over medium heat next I had in my diced
tomatoes white kidney beans pumpkin
puree chili powder chipotle in adobo
sauce cumin and cinnamon simmer on
medium low heat for 20 minutes before
adding in the turkey and stirring to
warm through finally season with a pinch
adjust all the pepper and strips of lime
juice
now the key to any good leftover turkey
meal is to start with a really good
high-quality turkey I've been known to
elicit some occasional miracles in the
kitchen but there's no amount of cheese
or bread that can disguise ingredients
VESA I love using the River Terrace
free-range turkeys because they're
raised on an all grain diet free from
any antibiotics animal by-products or
attic or meals and make Hawk essential
nutrients like omega threes no your
turkeys story folks next my individual
turkey Shepherd's pies over medium heat
i saute sliced leeks carrots and celery
in a tablespoon of olive oil until soft
before adding in some minced garlic then
I add some dry white wine until the
alcohol absorbs then stir in some whole
wheat flour and fresh thyme leaves into
the flour piece of light toasty Brown
add a couple cups of leftover turkey
broth and simmer until tender and
thickened next I add in my cooked
shredded turkey and any leftover
Brussels sprouts green beans parsnips or
carrots transfer to four ramekins and
top with a spoonful of leftover
cranberry sauce and a layer of leftover
mashed sweet potatoes and bake for 10 to
15 minutes at 350 degrees until bubbly
and golden and finally my turkey
breastess spreads pass I heat a
tablespoon of extra virgin olive oil in
a cast-iron skillet and add some
shredded leftover Brussels sprouts on
the
leftover roasted carrots parsnips
roasted potatoes and whatever herb fish
pie piquant got on here stir then add in
a cup of leftover turkey and season with
salt and pepper to taste
make a few wells and crack a few eggs
and some and bake them at 350 degrees
until the whites are set and the yolks
are still running and delicious
see you guys leftovers don't need to be
leftovers for long with all these great
new ideas you're gonna be wishing that
you cooked up a whole extra turkey just
to enjoy these recipes but thanks so
much for watching guys more great
quality helpers and kitchen inspiration
be sure to subscribe to my channel and
I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to Abbey's kitchen today we're
gonna be talking about antioxidants we
hear the word all the time we know we
should be getting more of them but why
are they even important anyway although
give you the old biochemistry textbook
definitions antioxidants are substances
that counter up the processes of
oxidation in the body and too much
oxidation is Baggies there